- On our show,
we want to put a spotlight
on people doing real good,
out in the real world.
And as the wildfires continue
to affect the West Coast,
there are countless stories
of heroes risking their lives
to help save their neighbors.
And our next guest is one of those heroes.
Having saved countless lives
and countless other homes,
while losing her own home.
Joining us from Oregon,
please welcome the Upper
McKenzie Rural Fire Chief,
Chief Christiana Rainbow Plews.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- Hello, Chief Rainbow.
Oh, I'm so--
- Hi, thanks for having me.
- I was just gonna say
thank you for coming here.
( Chief Rainbow laughs)
Take us through everything.
How has your community
been affected by the fires?
- The community is completely devastated,
Blue River's gone.
It's a small town in the
Cascade Foothills in Oregon
and it is completely gone.
Not only all the homes
but all the businesses
including our fire station.
- Oh! And--
- Eight of my volunteer
firefighters have lost
all of their belongings and their homes.
- And you lost your home,
Right, Chief Rainbow?.
- I did,
I did. I lost my home
and my neighboring home
where my boys were
roommates as also thought.
- Oh! How have you dealt with this?
How have you been able to
handle everything that's been
you know, put on your plate
that you've been confronted with?
How are you coping?
- It's really a roller coaster.
I'm up and down,
one minute I feel like
I'm strong enough to handle all of it
and the next minute, I don't know,
really lost.
I've been getting my
strength from my family,
and I know that my firefighters
are also gaining strength
from their families.
And,
our strong,
partners all around us
in the fire community,
are really supporting us.
- Can I ask you a question
because watching this story,
I think of the person
in me that is here
watching a television in my kitchen.
How do you tell yourself,
I've lost my home,
my boys are struggling,
I'm struggling.
What is the flip, the switch you flip
to go back out there
and keep helping others
while you're dealing with that?
- Somebody has to do it.
Somebody has to lead and
somebody has to help,
get the healing
and the,
rebuilding process started.
And I am the chief
and I am in the position
to impact that.
So, I just have to be strong
and I have to do it
for everyone else.
And hopefully, we can all find our way.
- We would like to do something
for you, Chief Rainbow.
I was so invested in your story
and we spoke to our friends at Pastene,
the oldest Italian specialty
foods in North America.
And they were just incredible
and they responded,
and we wanted to give you
this $10,000 cheque
on behalf of them
(audience applause)
and all of us at the show.
And I know it's not enough,
(audience continues clapping)
but just a little start to say
that you are an inspiration to us all.
And I'm going to be replaying
that in my mind over and over
that when you're in some
of the hardest situations,
how you flip that switch
and care for others.
I have learned a lot from you.
And I just thank you for your
dedication and inspiration
and talking with us today.
So here's--
- That's too much
a little something not enough,
but I thank our friends at Pastene,
and thank you Chief Rainbow for
being the example to us all.
We'll be right back.
- Thank you so much Drew.
Thank you. Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
(high intensity techno music)